China has a lung linguistic tradition.
Did you know Chinese scholars?
We're digging into old pronunciations
centuries before Europeans were
reconstructing prodo languages.
This is the tale of how they uncovered
their ancient imperial language.
Yeah,
I struggle with Chinese pronunciation.
I have ever since the
dictionary and cassettes,
my granddad once gave me for my birthday,
but lately I've been burying myself in
hundreds of pages of Chinese linguistic
history, and you know
what? I'm in good company,
Chinese pronunciation puzzled
experts in China for a long,
long time.
Like this fellow,
a scholar reconstructing a language in
the 1840s you know this story by now,
I've told it before.
Compare a group of related languages.
Classify them into a family tree,
then reconstruct their common ancestor.
Oh,
but that's not the story this time.
This scholar is Chumley.
He's confronting a centuries old problem.
How do you recover?
This sounds immortalized in
classical texts. How do you
make the old poems, Ryan?
Again, here's the catch.
You have no recordings,
no phonetic transcriptions,
not even an alphabet.
You're working with characters.
The Han characters we've
talked about here before.
Each one's standing for a one
syllable word or word peace.
He scrutinizes the book in front
of him. It looks old, stodgy even,
but it has quite a backstory.
1,261 years earlier,
uh,
Mister Lou invited eight friends
over for a slumber party.
They started their evening with wine
and conversation, but late in the night,
the friendly chitchat turned into a
heated debate over the exact pronunciation
of old texts. The way people recite them
in the north is wrong. No, they're wrong.
In the south enough talk,
Mr Lou inked his brush and outlined
what would become the t a. N.
He eventually filled five scrolls with
over 11,000 characters divided among the
four Chinese tones and
subdivided into rhyming groups.
Then he broke down the
sound of each character.
How with two more characters and upper
character to match the initial consonant
and it'll lower character to rhyme with
the final sounds including the tone.
Take the character here,
meaning east.
It had the initial of duck
and the final of UHMM.
So using the reconstructed pronunciation,
we'll talk about it at the end.
It's done with this method called funds.
Yeah,
you can capture the sound of a syllable,
simple and clever,
but it stopped short of giving an overview
of Chinese phonology for that Reimers
needed to take step.
Organize this info into tables.
The 12th century Rhyme Mirror is full
of rhyme tables. Here's one of them.
The very first table in the book,
the starting label gives the table number,
number one, and the kind of rhyme.
These syllables have a sort of uhm,
along the top row are six articulation
categories for consonants and down the
side,
the four tones,
the four rows per tone give
more info about the syllable,
but their interpretation is debated.
So try this,
find me a tongue sound.
A lingual that's clear,
meaning voiceless and has the first tone.
So for this syllable type,
we've pieced together something like doom.
And then there's a partly clear one,
meaning aspirated.
So kind of a tone.
And this one is dirty or muddy,
which means a voiced sound.
So maybe don't,
okay.
What about all these circles though?
What do they mean syllable not found?
So when you look for a lip sound that's
clear for the first tone in this chart,
you find nothing like boom recorded here,
but there is a boom mug
wards just like that.
You're excavating old pronunciations,
Chinese rhyme style and so confidence
scholars spent centuries sounding out
ancient Chinese syllables and teaching.
The Chinese had exactly
36 initial consonants,
but Chung Lee's not convinced.
He's combing through old fund ca
meticulously chaining together initials of
initials and finals of finals
is linked sets revealed flaws.
There weren't 36 initials,
there were 41 five of them
needed to be split in two,
but there's more.
The sounds in the rhyme tables
are not the sounds in the tin.
These are two different stages.
Later research,
we'll go on to show that even the
earlier stage itself is complicated.
It's a compromise between
ancient literary dialects.
Thinking back to those late night
debates over the north versus the south,
that sounds about right,
but all this hard work merely
left us with categories, boxes,
boxes for four tones, boxes
for initials, boxes for finals.
The enough with the guesswork.
What are the precise sounds that
really fit into these boxes.
In the early 19 hundreds of Swede traveled
to China and dug into the old rhymes
and tables,
but then added an important piece,
the many living varieties of
Chinese call green was fascinated.
He created surveys and set out to document
them and he used his results to fill
out the rhyme categories with real sounds.
How well take that fourth tone also
called the checked tone along the southern
coast. He's checked tones,
syllables have a final stop sound.
So this old character meaning
country is or in Mandarin,
but in Cantonese it's who's older?
Well,
look at the last three languages
in Kellgren's list of dialects,
Korean, Japanese, and Vietnamese.
They use Sino, Zenith pronunciations,
meaning China, foreign.
Basically the way the characters
sounded to them when they were imported,
their words also have that k it points
back to an ancient pronunciation for that
character that ended in a consonant like
linguists went on to refine these
reconstructions and to paint acoustic
portraits of ancient Chinese
that put sound downright
foreign in Mandarin. Today.
They even revealed small
but important distinctions.
Calgrin missed like these pairs of
Tromeo and they taught me one last thing
while I was over here struggling to
understand Chinese pronunciation.
It's not a single language
called ancient Chinese. No,
it's a period in linguistic
history, cold, middle,
Chinese middle,
because there's an even
older language to uncover.
A thousand years older still.
Maybe one day we'll rhyme our
way into old Chinese until then.
Stick around and subscribe for language.